- Well, you share a lot of
your life on social media,
so I was wondering if
you could walk us through
some of these posts.
- Okay, okay.
Oh gosh, I don't know what I post.
- [Kelly] Here is one about
your Zoom setup skills.
- [Olivia] Oh right.
- [Kelly] So first you have your stand
and yep, that's your stand and then this.
Yeah?
And then finally, we have,
- [Olivia] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- [Olivia] So you got
everyone's Zooms now.
Everyone is zooming.
It is so difficult, I don't know.
- [Kelly] Is that a bra?
Was it a bra in the back?
- [Olivia] Wait, it's an eye mask.
- [Kelly] It's an eye mask.
It looked like the cup of a bra,
and I was like, that's
just being like smart.
- So this is what happens, is that
I've been doing a lot
of early morning press
to like hit the news stations in New York.
And like, so like three AM
is when I have to get up.
And so then my hair and makeup
team who I'm very close with,
I let them stay over and they actually,
I let them sleep in my
bed, Kylie and Carly.
They sleep in my bed and I
sleep on the couch so that when
we wake up in the morning, I
don't have a very big house.
So we wake up in the
morning, I'm on the couch,
but I need my eye mask because
the light fills the room.
So that's why my eye mask was right there.
- [Kelly] You give your bed away?
I'm still on that.
- To Carly and Kylie.
Yeah, because we all
have to get up so early,
literally like three AM all the time.
- No, I get it, I get it, I do it too.
- So then they, we, they roll out of bed.
I roll off the couch and then
I'm putting together my Zoom
situation, which is very different
every time the light changes, you know?
It's very, it's very
difficult to do it yourself.
I don't know how I went
through the whole pandemic
and I never asked anybody for
help just figuring it out.
I was like oh.
- Literally the only
thing that helped me is my
assistant got me a ring light,
because that was the only thing that
and shut off all the windows there,
so no light would change it.
- My sister sent me one
because she was like,
you're not doing it right.
My sister's a lawyer and
she has to be on Zoom.
She's like, you're not doing it right,
she sent it to me and I didn't
know how to put it together.
- Oh, I'm not, I am not, my
I had to have my assistant help me do it,
I'm not tech savvy at all.
And mine was put up with
books and a girl, I,
yours was like a tiny bit
raised. I'd raise it all up.
Make it look looks my angle now.
- Yeah, I've done that.
I've done the thing when you look up
and then this is my, this is the camera.
So this, this is me on all my Zooms.
And it's just my neck
like this, I look crazy.
So then I was like, no,
we'll go down with it.
And then I looked like
this for most of them.
- You look on the ring,
the girl, the ring.
- Oh my God, yeah.
I'm just like
seven days.